Barack Obama alone
could house every single migrant that
has been sent to Martha's Vineyard
Barack Obama has a 12 million dollar
mansion on Martha's Vineyard it's almost
7 000 square feet it's got seven
bedrooms but even that okay so seven
bedrooms that could that alone could
probably almost has all of the illegal
immigrants but Barack Obama's got 30
Acres
this guy has so much land if if Barack
Obama wanted a real political Master
stroke here he would open up his home
he's got the best security in the world
he doesn't need to worry about that
he's not even there he could open up his
home
allow the 50 migrants and he would look
like an absolute hero who would be such
a master stroke
but he won't do it none of these people
will do it let's talk a really really
good game when the migrants are over a
thousand miles away down on the border
but they don't want these people the
only time that the wealthy Democrats of
Martha's Vineyard are going to allow any
Latin Americans anywhere near them is
when they're mowing their lawns